you guys just wrapped the sixth and
final season
of lucifer what were those last days
like
i won't lie it was really sad
um it's a lot of tears and i think this
show is um
well i know the show is special too to
all of us i mean we
we started as this little show that no
one really believed in
except um the fans the lucifer fans and
uh
and and critics um and you know we
started
in vancouver you know these really dark
and rainy nights which
in a lovely way forced all of us to
really get to know each other
and we became a this incredible family
and then moving back to l.a and then
getting cancelled and then getting
saved and then this is our last season
and then it's not our last season and um
it's i've never been part of a show uh
that's had this kind of
um journey and roller coaster
yeah yeah it's been incredible who was
the most emotional
on that final day um
well it's it's we technically we still
have about
six days left it's just that we've had
final
scenes with people so so um
uh that's yet
i will see because our very final day
all of us are together
for uh one scene i think they plan it
that way to kind of to get us
all together crying and sobbing so they
get it on film
but tom and i had our last scene
together last week and um
i won't lie we were both uh blubbering
idiots um
we were just uh could not stop crying oh
well you guys are
our brothers yeah you know and and it's
also we just
you know i think i was saying this
earlier to someone when you're when
you're there and you're shooting your
last scene it's this weird thing because
you know it's your last scene and you're
looking at this person
in their eyes as you're as you're saying
your lines and what's flashing before
your eyes is
all the memories from the first time of
meeting tom
us um at that time being single dads
talking about what it's like
being being dads to uh little girls and
and how challenging that was for us
about trying to balance the
you know wanting to give them everything
because we love them so much to trying
to
you know also have some discipline in
how our intelligent beautiful little
girls were
walking all over us you know
so uh you know girl dads yeah
yeah and so you so you're thinking about
all that stuff while you're trying to
like
not cry through these takes uh um
so i love the guy you know it's been a
it's been a
it's been a great ride what an exciting
moment at the same time that everything
is kind of sad it's bittersweet because
you're also making your directorial
debut so first of all what was it like
for you to put on the director's
hat it was uh it was amazing you know
it's it's something that i've wanted to
do for
for a really long time uh and you know i
think sometimes what's hard is when you
know you can do something and you have a
unique voice as i believe i do and i see
things visually
it's hard in the business that that that
we're in
to have people that are
that pragmatic people that that need to
be pragmatic
take a leap of faith you know they they
they know you as a certain entity and
that's what they're comfortable with and
so it was
a very heavy lift to uh to to get people
to
see me in a different way i just turned
in my director's cut
and um it's been amazing
and it you know it's it was challenging
it was
it was difficult but it was the most
rewarding
enjoyable experience that i've ever had
in my life
do you feel like because you've acted
alongside of
this cast for so long it it helped
you to direct them definitely definitely
because the episode that that
i have you know it was there were a lot
of directors that i
shadowed who when they found out the
episode that i was given
uh they were like i can't believe that
they gave you that one you have
everyone all episode dealing with um
uh everyone's personalities everyone's
quirks from in front of the camera to
behind the camera you know
um but i but i also think that there was
some thinking
in the episode that they gave me and
that i have a relationship
with everyone for the past six seasons
and so they were
really leaning into that yeah um i think
that
that that really helped what episode did
you
direct i ended up directing episode uh
season six episode eight and it's the
and i think it's safe to say this it's
the last episode
uh that where it's the the first and
last um
episode where you have the entire cast
all the characters in it from beginning
to end
so we've never really had that so
juggling
all of them for so many days uh
was really challenging but i think we
made something really special
uh and unique that uh that fans are
gonna really dig
i think that everyone felt they had a
great opportunity because there was
something
in there for every character so so
essentially for
for every actor um and we're gonna get a
chance to
to see them in a different different
light
um it's it's you know one long
night um where they're all together
and as we all know you know when you're
hanging out with friends
uh from you know late afternoon to the
next morning
you're all in the same space things come
out people start
sharing talking and you have all of
these
magical moments how do you feel about
the real ending of the show
now will fans be satisfied were you
happy with the way that amena deal
sort of wrapped up yes um um
yes and yes uh i think fans will be
satisfied i think fans will be happy
um i'm satisfied it's been an incredible
journey i definitely think that as
i'm sure you've heard from most shows
right who are that are going off now
filming during covid has been really
challenging so
i have no doubt that if we weren't in
covid we might have done some things
differently
i think maybe we would have brought some
cast members back
that we didn't get a chance to to bring
back anyone come to mind specifically
no i i i can't say because we do
manage to i can say this we do manage to
bring back
um i'll say this
the cast members that we do bring back
um people will be very happy to
see them i'll just that's good so we're
getting some surprise returns
yes yeah i think it's safe to say that
after
5a came out the showrunners told me that
5b
is perhaps the most emotional season
would you agree with that and if so how
so i would definitely agree with that um
absolutely uh dennis haysberg who who
plays good old dad
god who uh you know we're reunited after
24 which is awesome
he's gonna be a um
there all throughout 5b his presence
will be
felt he has incredible scenes with
both both his sons dennis gets to act
with
every member of the cast whether they
know he's god or not um there are going
to be
you know incredible moments there